at last Mario Kart 8 returns with the
deluxe edition complete with every
single track from the original plus a
few extras thrown in veterans of the
series will feel right at home with the
game but for all you switch owners out
there who are new to it and haven't
quite discovered all the alternate paths
in the courses we've got for you the
eight shortcuts that will change the way
you race in Mario Kart 8 forever now if
you haven't picked up the game yet go
watch our video review buy games plus
own Cali play II buy it and wait
patiently for the mailman to come ok you
ready let's do this
[Music]
we'll start off with the Wii U version
of Rainbow Road because why not after
jumping the first gap onto the red and
green conveyor belts make sure you board
the next ramp on the right side from
there you'll have a straight shot for
this shortcut look for the turn after
the spin boost pillar and drive off the
course to the left side and you should
land on the alternate track underneath
now keep driving and leap off this ledge
back onto the original track and if all
goes according to plan you will have
shaved a couple seconds off your time
and hopefully be in good position to
take first place
[Music]
this one's a little bit simpler but it
can be just as risky cloudtop cruz has
you bouncing around in the sky but if
you dare you can take the shortcut right
at the very end of course
see those two leaves poking out from the
Beanstalk make a hard right after
landing on this section and you'll be
able to jump on to them and straight to
the finish line but if you're looking
for an even better finishing shortcut
well
both of these courses feature some of
the most treacherous shortcuts out there
and both are right before their final
turns in shy guy falls after you fly off
the waterfall keep a lookout on the
right side for a narrow grassy road
you'll need to use a mushroom to boost
through it and make the jump but make
sure you drift right away to avoid
flying off the left side after you land
and same goes for mute city the ramp is
a little more hidden but take a right
here and you'll be treated to a nice
relaxing jump that ends in the checkered
flag
[Music]
ah yes Hyrule Castle has its own course
in Mario Kart 8 deluxe and it comes with
an awesome-looking shortcut right in the
center of the castle there's a good
chance you'll need the help of some of
the other racers to activate it but once
you hit all the spin boost pillars on
the stairs a ramp will open up for you
and anyone else nearby to use it may not
save you the most time but there's
arguably nothing cooler than jumping
straight through the Master Sword but if
you're looking for some massive
time-saving jumps that'll bump you up a
couple places in the standings try
ribbon roads to shortcuts take a right
as soon as you board the floating ribbon
portion of the track and jump over the
giant toy bear then immediately take
another right to hit this ramp and float
into the final turn these shortcuts are
riskier than most but when everyone is
bouncing around trying to drip those
turns
you'll be gliding comfortably into first
place
[Music]
technically speaking yoshi Valley has no
shortcuts instead there are multiple
roads that branch off from each other
meaning there are a bunch of different
ways that you can complete the course
but which path should you take well
there is an optimal path to follow and
it goes like this on the first fork in
the road make a left and then continue
making the left until you reach that
narrow wooden bridge once you cross it
you should be in good position to take
first place or get hit by a red shell
both outcomes are equally likely
[Music]
Mountain Wario is one of the most
competitive and rage-inducing courses
out there you'll have to make your way
from the summit of the mountain down to
the base all while avoiding cliffs
dodging trees and dealing with all sorts
of BS power-ups along the way but if you
want to separate yourself from the crowd
try these two shortcuts in the first
area of the course there are a few
hairpin turns that you'll need to watch
out for but during the curve right
before the cave entrance you can drift a
little early hop off the small ramp and
cut the turnout completely the second
short cut is a little more hidden and
you'll need a mushroom for it but it's
well worth the effort after the section
with the dam you'll come to another fork
in the road you can go left you can go
right but instead we're going straight
boost through the snow right here and
you'll be treated with a jump that will
bypass some of the trickier turns
through the forest an honorable mention
goes to ice ice outpost because despite
the course having two alternate paths
that will save you a lot of time the low
friction and narrow ramps just make the
shortcuts way too risky to recommend
I would say not to waste your energy on
it and just concentrate on dealing with
the courses slippery roads instead so
those are our picks for the eight best
shortcuts in Mario Kart 8 plus one that
you probably should just avoid if you
have a favorite way of getting ahead of
the pack of aside from a blue shell of
course posting in the comments below and
then we can argue about it because what
is Mario Kart if not unadulterated rage
and fury
my name is Joey and thanks for watching
[Music]